Salut, aujourd'hui on est samedi
je suis toujours à Aix-en-Provence où je joue ce soir et demain
Donc je vous fais le premier MasterClass'
depuis ce magnifique théatre
Aujourd'hui je commence... le MasterClass' !!!
C'est la classe !
Mercredi, souvenez-vous, je vous ai parlé de comment retenir un numéro de téléphone à la volée
Quand on vous donne un numéro de téléphone, maintenant
vous pouvez créer une petite scenette
dans votre tête pour le retenir
Vous allez avoir plein
de dessins animés en tête grâce à moi
Mais on peut aller beaucoup plus loin que ça !
Grâce à ce que l'on appelle la table de rappel !
L'idée est toute simple, elle consiste à convertir tous les nombres de 1 à 100 en image
Ca permet de rendre concret dans son esprit
des choses aussi irréelles que "deux"
2, on ne peut pas se le représenter...
Par contre, si on a une image à la place de 2,
on peut se représenter cette image.
C'est un petit peu comme un code secret
une table de rappel
comme une carte aux trésors de la mémoire
Alors est-ce que vous voulez devenir des pirates de la mémoire avec moi ?
Arrêtez de vous prendre pour Jack Sparrow,
Je vais quand même vous expliquer
à quoi ça va vous servir au quotidien.
Vous allez pouvoir avec ça choper n'importe quel numéro de téléphone qu'on vous donne
mais plus que ça !
N'importe quelle séquence de chiffres
Ça peut être un numéro de carte bleue,
ça peut être des codes pour quelque chose,
Ça peut être un numéro de réservation
pour les billets d'avion,
ça peut être aussi des choses plus basiques :
votre liste de course,
votre liste des choses
que vous devez emmener à tel endroit.
Ça peut être... les points clés d'un discours
Vous pouvez quasiment tout retenir avec ça !
C'est la table de rappel et c'est extrêmement pratique !
On devrait même apprendre ça aux enfants.
en primaire, selon moi, c'est mon avis.
Pour que vous puissiez construire votre table de rappel,
votre espèce d'aide mémoire, tu vois, de convertisseur
pour savoir à quelles images
correspondent chaque chiffre
il existe plusieurs méthodes :
il y en a une qui est très populaire
chez les sportifs de la mémoire,
Oui, y'a des sportifs de la mémoire, Monsieur !
C'est la méthode de Pierre Hérigone,
Pierre Hérigone,
C'était un mathématicien et un astronome,
français d'ailleurs, du XVIIème siècle
Et il a inventé  une méthode pour construire ses images
et se rappeler de quelle image on avait mis.
Il a créé un code à partir de consonnes
C'est à dire qu'il a attribué
une consonne à chaque chiffre
1 c'est  T,  3 c'est M, 4 c'est R
Il a attribué ce code-là
Et pour construire son image :
il reprend les consonnes et
il rajoute des voyelles entre les deux.
C'est pas clair ?
pour créer l'image qu'il va associer au chiffre 31 :
Il regarde 31, ça fait 3 et 1,
Et les chiffres qui composent le nombre 31sont 3 et 1.
Et 3, dans sa méthode à lui,
ça correspond à la lettre M
M parce qu'en fait, 3 quand on le penche,
ça fait penser à un M
Et le  1, ça correspond à un T
Parce qu'un T, ça ressemble un petit peu à un 1
avec cette grande barre, ok ?
Donc ça fait M et T
Donc si on rajoute des voyelles entre tout ça,
on peut faire "MouTon"
Donc l'image pour 31, ça va être un mouton !
Si on prend le 43, ça fait R et M,
si on rajoute des voyelles,
on peut obtenir RaMe.
On peut avoir l'image d'une rame en 43.
Est-ce que vous comprenez
de mieux en mieux ce principe ?
Vous n'êtes pas obligé de suivre cette méthode.
Il en existe d'autres, et surtout
il existe.... la vôtre !
C'est très important parce que votre table de rappel,
elle va vous servir beaucoup
et elle doit vous correspondre
Vous vous souvenez,
toujours dans la situation de mercredi dernier,
Je vous disais : " 22 ça me fait penser aux flics"
Mais 22, ça vous fait peut-être penser à
votre département de naissance
ou à une date clé pour vous, à une date de mariage
j'en sais rien, en fait
il faut vraiment que la table de rappel,
elle vous corresponde.
C'est très important
Ca va vous aider à maitriser cet outil
qui est extrêmement puissant.
Ma méthode personnelle, c'est d'utiliser la rime numérique avec une constante.
- Ok.. Je te vois partir discrètement de cette vidéo...
... une rime numérique avec constante ?...
... on va s'arrêter là Fabien...
... c'était sympa tes vidéos....
N'ayez pas peur ! C'est pas très grave
Une rime numérique, c'est quoi ?
C'est à dire que je fais rimer la fin
de la prononciation du nombre ou du chiffre
avec la prononciation de mon image
Un exemple tout bête :
En 1, j'ai l'image d'un sapin
En 2, j'ai l'image du feu
En 3, j'ai l'image d'une croix
En 4, j'ai l'image d'un plâtre.
En 5, c'est un bar
mais en vrai dans ma tête, c'est un zinc
En 6, j'ai une scie,
En 7,  une tête
En 8, une huître
En 9, c'est un oeuf,
En 10, c'est la police, là pour le coup
j'ai un policier mais dans un commissariat
En 11, j'ai le penseur de Rodin parce que 11
ça me fait penser à bronze, et bronze : la statue
Vous voyez, c'est mon propre chemin.
En 12, j'ai de la pelouse
En 13, une fraise
Et si on va plus loin que ça,
en 30, j'ai une tente
En 31, j'ai un porçin,
Et en 32, j'ai un pneu
Et en 33,  j'ai un plat
Et en 34, un pirate
Est-ce que vous remarquez où elle est ma constante ?
Elle est dans la première lettre !
Toutes les images de mes trentaines,
donc de 30 à 39,
ça commence par un P.
C'est un code que je me suis mis.
Comme ça, si je n'ai pas révisé ma table de rappel depuis longtemps et qu'on me dit : 66
Je sais que tous mes 60 commencent  par la lettre S, systématiquement.
Et je sais que ça va finir par un truc comme "isse"
Et en fait, ça me revient instantanément,
c'est saucisse !
En l'occurence, mon 66, c'est une saucisse !
Bien, alors pour créer votre table de rappel,
Il faut commencer par créer votre grille à vous,
ne vous prenez pas trop la tête pour les 20 premiers,
essayez de faire des choses
qui vous parlent vraiment, vraiment
qui vous parlent comme ça, instantanément
ce qui vous vient, il sera toujours
le temps d'en refaire une
si vous voulez un jour ou même, d'en avoir plusieurs.
J'ai un ami qui s'appelle Benoit Rosemont,
qui est un grand spécialiste de la mémoire
qui joue sur scène aussi également.
Il a je-ne-sais-pas-combien de tables de rappel
Voilà, il passe de l'une à l'autre.
Moi j'en ai que 2, c'est déjà bien
Vous pouvez en créer plusieurs
mais j'en ai des petites par contre,
j'en ai de nombreuses petites.
De 1 à 20, ça me permet de stocker différentes informations dans ma tête.
Commencer par créer votre table de rappel,
on va dire 10 à 20 mots pour commencer.
Et mémorisez-les.
Pour les mémoriser, c'est pas compliqué, il faut les reprendre régulièrement,
Retrouver votre logique, vous le faire en permanence,
vous amuser à le faire.
Et pour ça vous avez de la chance,
il existe plein de temps morts dans la vie,
dans vos journées.
Il existe énormément d'endroits où vous ne faites rien de spécial, où mentalement vous êtes relativement inactif.
Comme moi hein, c'est le cas pour tout le monde
Ca peut être dans les embouteillages,
ça peut être aux toilettes,
ben oui, vous pouvez rentabiliser le temps
que vous passez aux toilettes, haha !
Quand vous êtes dans une file d'attente,
quand vous écoutez quelqu'un et
que ça ne vous intéresse pas trop, ce qu'il raconte.
Il y a plein de moments où
vous pouvez vous entrainer comme ça,
et donc vous vous testez vous-même.
Le but c'est que ça devienne aussi naturel
pour vous que votre alphabet.
Votre alphabet, vous n'y réfléchissez pas quand
vous le dites, vous le dites.
Et puis c'est tout. Tout vient.
Et bien là, c'est pareil
et c'est même encore plus fort !
Ca doit devenir aussi naturel
mais en plus dissociatif
Quand on vous dira 14, vous aurez tout de suite l'image du 14 qui vous reviendra en tête.
Quand on vous dira 22,
vous aurez votre image du 22,
voir même : quand vous verrez une image
qui est dans votre table de rappel
vous allez penser instantanément au chiffre
Et là, c'est que vous touchez le bon bout
... Et non pas le bambou...
Donc prenez le temps vraiment de mémoriser
ces 20 premières occurrences.
Toutes les images que vous allez associées de 1 à 20 : Prenez le temps de les maitriser.
Vraiment, vraiment, vraiment.
Et une fois que c'est fait,
vous rajoutez 10 nouvelles images en plus
On va dire une fois par mois.
Ca c'est très très bien ou alors vous en rajoutez
10 par semaine si vous êtes très motivé.
Mais il vaut mieux prendre son temps
et en 1 an, avoir une belle table de rappel
bien fournie et bien maitrisée
que de vouloir aller trop vite et de se rater.
Le but idéalement,
c'est d'atteindre 100 images, de 0 à 99.
Ca c'est très bien, ça permet de retenir
plein de choses en séquençant par deux.
Et concrètement, comment vous allez-vous en servir ?
Je vous redonne encore
l'exemple du numéro de téléphone
Si là, on vous donne un numéro de téléphone,
donc c'est 5 nombres à 2 chiffres,
Vous n'avez plus que 5 images à retenir.
Vous n'avez même pas à les chercher,
vous les connaissez déjà ces images.
Vous comprenez la puissance de ça ?
Comme ce sont vos images à vous,
vous allez retenir ça très facilement.
5 images à retenir.. C'est très très facile.
Vous pouvez après les relier entre elles, pour faire une petite action comme on a vu mercredi,
Et ça vous donne une scènette que
vous maitrisez vraiment parfaitement.
On peut vous donner un numéro de téléphone
en une seule fois,
ça vous fait naitre tout de suite les images,
y'a pas de recherche,
vous allez retenir tout de suite !
Si vous devez retenir... une liste de course ?
Une liste de course :
vous allez associer les images ensemble
Par exemple, le premier objet de la liste de course,
c'est un pack de lait
Ok ? Vous allez prendre votre image du 1
Moi en l'occurrence, c'est un sapin
Ben moi dans ma tête, je vais imaginer mon sapin,
sur lequel on est en train de renverser du lait
Je crée une image mentale
J'ai pas besoin d'apprendre cette image
J'ai juste besoin de la visualiser une fois
Mon sapin sur lequel coule plein, plein, plein de lait.
Et je vais faire comme ça
avec chaque objet de la liste de course
Vous pouvez faire ça en l'associant avec l'image correspondante à son rang.
Donc le cinquième truc que vous devez acheter, vous l'imaginez avec votre image n°5.
Si par exemple, ce sont des pâtes
moi, j'vais imaginer des pâtes
sur un zinc de bar encore bien fumantes
Encore une fois vous n'avez pas à mémoriser
cette association d'idées,
Juste à la visualiser !
Et comme notre mémoire est magnifique,
elle retient ça tout de suite
Parce que c'est du concret
Et donc, quand vous irez faire vos courses,
Vous aurez juste à vous remémorer
l'ordre de vos images.
Donc en image 1, j'ai un sapin.
"Ah oui, y'a du lait qui coule..."
donc il faut que j'aille chercher du lait
En 2, j'avais quoi ? .... etcetera...etcetera...
En 5, je vois mon zinc avec des pâtes dessus,
Il faut que j'aille chercher des pâtes
Après c'est très facile,
vous vous rendez compte ?
Vous n'apprenez plus, juste, vous visualisez et votre cerveau stocke naturellement !
Ça permet aussi de retenir les points clés d'un discours,
(si vous faites des discours)
Ça permet de retenir les points clés
de n'importe quelle argumentation
Si vous devez argumenter des choses, faire une soutenance, ou dans vos cours.
Ça permet de se donner des images
aussi pour l'histoire de France
pour tout ce que vous voulez
Vous pouvez convertir
tous les nombres et les chiffres !
Voici votre nouveau super-pouvoir !
Convertissez les nombres et les chiffres
en image dans votre tête
Stockez-les, arrêtez d'apprendre,
et maîtriser votre mémoire !
Dans une autre vidéo master-class du samedi,
disons dans 1 mois ou 2,
le temps que vous maîtrisiez cet outil-là,
je vous apprendrais maintenant à l'utiliser
pour des choses encore plus hallucinantes
Pour retenir par exemple,
l'ordre des cartes dans un jeu de cartes,
Comme je l'ai fait dans une vidéo,
Y'a une méthode qui existe pour ça, mais il faut commencer par la table de rappel.
Je pourrais aussi vous apprendre comme ça
à retenir un mot qui n'est pas visualisable
La confiance,
la confiance n'a pas d'image
Y'a des astuces qui permettent
d'associer des mots abstraits
comme confiance, amitié, bonheur ou... un nom de médicament par exemple
à vos images de table de rappel.
Tout ça, on en parlera dans un autre MasterClass',
Déjà, commencez à écrire votre grille
Apprenez-là, étoffez-la,
essayez de la faire grossir jusqu'à 99
Mais déjà, ayez 20, 25, 30 mots,
ce sera déjà super
j'espère que cette vidéo MasterClass',
elle vous a plu,
j'espère surtout que vous allez pouvoir bosser ça
et vous en servir au quotidien
Je crois que c'est ce qui me ferait le plus plaisir
C'est que ça vous aide, d'une manière ou d'une autre, à maîtriser un peu mieux votre mémoire.
N'hésitez pas aussi à apprendre ça
le plus tôt possible aux enfants
Je me dis que si les enfants maîtrisaient
ce genre d'outil,
ce serait beaucoup plus symple pour eux ensuite.
Voilà, j'espère que cette nouvelle vidéo vous a plu.
C'est un nouveau format pour moi,
ce sera tous les samedis comme ça
N'hésitez pas à mettre un pouce en l'air, un petit commentaire si vous avez des questions
je me ferai un grand, grand plaisir d'y répondre
Abonnez-vous à la chaîne vraiment, vraiment...
J'attends que vous vous abonniez...
... et il regarde encore et il ne s'abonne pas...
Abonnez-vous à la chaine et rendez-vous demain à 11h pour le prochain MentalVlog
Tchao !